hey everybody i'm josh wolfe and i'm
weird
what was that okay all right
lucky for me the world is weirder than
ever you can either lock your doors or
pick up a tambourine and join the parade
it's up to you so sit back
relax and let's get weird together
welcome to josh wolf's wonderful world
of weird
hey everybody here we are thanks for
joining me on my couch now i
it isn't exactly where i thought i'd be
filming my new
fancy facebook watch show but
thanks to a little something called
social distancing it's just
me you and this little video you're
about to see
here we are you should have seen what we
had planned we had
car crashes and people getting lit on
fire
and the rock he was a big part of it we
chose health and safety first
speaking of health and safety wait till
you meet irina bronski
and her little bloodthirsty friends who
she attached onto my body
hi hi josh come in come in
[Music]
hi hi good to see you thank you for
having me i can't wait to see what
you have in store for me i laugh
i really liked irene a lot she was
knowledgeable and
funny and friendly so would you like to
see my friends
yeah what are we they're waiting for you
okay do they smell something right now
is that why they're coming out yes they
smell that there is opportunity
to attach to someone and have a dinner i
got to tell you the truth the idea of
being called dinner
made me feel violated this one looks
like my agent
sorry silvio what's the difference
between this
leech and the leech like when you go
swimming at a lake
there are 600 species of glitches in the
nature and
only four officially approved as
medicinal
so if you don't know what kind of leach
attached you better remove it
i actually found a leech at a lake once
i dated her for like eight years
yeah that was a hard one to pull off you
know what i'm saying how long have you
been working with leeches
since 2011. is that when you moved to
los angeles um
[Laughter]
so what do you think is important for
you today to work on
well i have had some digestion issues i
had some lower back issues as well
leeches improve circulation people feel
very good
lots of energy this is a diaper this is
to help the
fluids that are going to be coming after
the treatment
wait till my neighbors see a bloody
adult diaper in the trash on trash day
they're going to be like
what here's the bathroom yeah yeah and
please use bathroom if you need and we
will start
uh i won't need to use a bathroom i got
a diaper okay
ready oh uh
actually you can have your jeans on and
your top
i'll just i'll just lower it and it will
work on your body so please
you sure i mean these are more
comfortable i thought they were gonna be
just put on your jeans and tops you sure
yes yes hey don't catch a pig on my way
back in you know what i'm saying
sorry about that it's okay it's okay so
lay down on your tummy
my tummy we're gonna be working first
some cupping and you probably won't
want to kind of like open your
so it will be easier yeah belt is off
and okay yeah yeah and open your pants
all right now lay on my stomach yes oh
okay
yep that doesn't feel impersonal yeah
she just smacked my ass and yeah i feel
pretty good about it
what does the cupping do brings fluids
to the surface to decongest
if there is any like a soreness in the
body
some leeches will go kind of under your
tailbone to
detox the root chakra it feels
like people sucking on my back
now what's happening now i'm flying one
beach
right now there's a leech on me yeah i
get i mean to say i was surprised by how
damp and wiggly it was
you know what that leech is dangerously
close to
yeah this is that's a good place not for
that leech ah
i was really hoping this would feel a
little better than it does
let's make up a leech song i got leeches
on my back
i got leeches in my crack i got leeches
on the front
ah leech fun not my best improv song but
i
think i was a little lightheaded from
losing all of that blood
now i'm gonna ask you to turn on your
side okay bend your knees yeah
yeah is that one going in my belly
button yes as it's sucking some blood
your lower back your small intestine
your kidneys everything kind of gets
you know but i'm going to put one more
underneath your tailbone i think
we call that the bottle medical benefit
of the underneath the tailbone
drains the spinal fluid very good for
people who have headaches
it's also detoxing the root chakra where
all the toxins
by the gravity goes down so i'm going to
lower your pants with your permission
yeah
with my permission do you accept this
leech i'm going to call
from here on out that's what i'm going
to call my butthole the root chakra
cheeks have been spread and
we've got landing oh yeah it's moving
oh boy okay done you're done
i still have a leech on my butthole so
i'm not quite
done how many do i have on my body right
now uh
six are there any parts of the body
where you won't
put a leech
[Music]
so do people ever put them on their
genitalia do they do that
yes and is that for blood flow yes
it improves for guys with erectile
dysfunction
chris she's talking to you why am i
wearing a diaper
you're going to have fluids coming out
from the lit this little bite
for six eight hours or with one of my
cracks moving around it tickles
ha ha sorry ah that felt funny it's only
30
blood the rest is lymphatic fluid
intracellular fluid interstitial flu
tears i feel i should have trimmed up
for him you know what i mean
how's that how you feeling does it look
cool
yeah that's the word yeah get a light in
there it's a little dark
it's very dangerous to pull why what
happens if you poke because a little
cheese
i thought it was just like a giant
sucker that explains a lot
i'm gonna feel that little dude down
near my beehole for the rest of the
night and be like oh
irena i just want you to know you've
done things that only my wife has done
before
i feel like we're really close well
they're so much bigger
they're so much bigger of course
hold with your hand and do ballerina
twist for me oh yeah
the ballerina twist actually seemed like
the perfect ending to this day
because what else are you supposed to do
i honestly feel awake
almost like i just had a cup of coffee
energy yeah energy i do feel a rush of
energy which is amazing
but at the same time i'm wearing a
diaper
so i don't know how i feel about that if
this made you uneasy
good go do it different it's good this
turned out to be fantastic oh don't
pretend like you don't know me now
you know what i'm saying don't pretend
like we ain't friends this guy's like i
was just in your b-hole
yeah give me your face yes thank you so
much
look you're supposed to take the leashes
home with you you know but uh because
you can't use
the same ones on other people and now
the only one i took home was the one on
my butthole
it seemed kind of wrong you know what i
mean to like
force something to to be put there and
then leave it like you didn't care you
know
see how big he grows he does look at me
kind of with those eyes you know like
you know me man next week on josh wolf's
wonderful world of weird get in just
jump in the car
stranger danger stranger danger i'm
candy payne
professional wrestler and i'm looking
for an adversary
i would love to wrestle you but i don't
want to wrestle you as like playing old
jobs
oh no you sound like a mad dad to me
i hope you're ready to fight candy cane
get in the ring
[Music]